you know who does need some milk michael
buble
bro apparently he was like dog [ __ ] at
singing that's what he said
at the be like the beginning of his
career and he like went to a vocal coach
and after a certain amount of time he
got good at singing
but really yeah he says that he was a
terrible singer
so you can get better at singing like i
know you can take vocal
lessons and i know you can work with a
vocal coach but i feel like that only
works for people that have the gift
gift of gab i think when he says he was
bad at singing i think it's like
he probably had power and range he just
had no clue how to use it so
yeah so that's not bad at singing right
but i mean i guess in context
huh like i'm i'm bad yeah there's no
part of my
voice box that's equipped for
anything of the sort yeah i mean we're
you know
neither you or i are ever we're always
going to be you know flat and at of key
i'll need to i'll need auto-tune for the
rest of my life i
i sent like a song i made to baby no
money and he was like he was like why
don't you
try and singing without tune and i was
like you don't even
you if i sent you that right now you
would delete my number
[Laughter]
dude such a like such an unintentionally
mean thing to say
i'd hate reading that over text i'd get
[ __ ] sensitive
oh man she tries you start singing that
without you you should try singing that
without auto tune
is that is that a is that a jab
did you just jab me did you like it
though yeah so are you saying
it's good you trying to embarrass me i i
don't like i know
that autotune is such a polarizing thing
now that i don't really
i don't get offended by that but i also
now i listen to short kings anthony and
i'm like what the [ __ ] were we thinking
putting that on my voice
um hey man like it what did you if we
just dialed it down like 10 notches it
would have sounded fine
i mean yeah i mean why did we keep it
cranked i mean
christian i'm i'ma just say let me just
say
christian i'm just deferred a christian
i'm not even gonna say it's his fault
i'm just deferring to christian
what the [ __ ] man why did you let me do
that
no i mean i don't know i really don't
know why we did that
i i mean it's still it's still bangs
it's still absolutely spanx yeah this is
in the whipparoonie but
it's not um it's not knock on christian
no it's no knock on christian at all i'm
just you know there's all this stuff
going on right now about people taking
advantage of impressionable artists
right right i say i feel that
yeah yeah i mean that's our 30 for 30.
you know i had a beautiful voice the
whole time and
you know i just i just felt like it was
never really like looked after or taken
care of
you know i'd sing into the mic and and
all of a sudden i'd hear it back with
layers and layers of auto-tune on it and
it's like why
and so i started to believe that i just
sucked
and everyone in the room kept
encouraging me mate keep it keep it keep
it
sounds dope dude and it just delayed me
years and years of my career because
this whole time i was just sitting on
a gem a gem of a voice and i mean it got
it got so bad it got to the point where
i would i had it installed
in my throat permanently yeah so that i
could you know if i was singing in the
in the car or the shower that's how it
started
is by you know times when i was singing
even alone i would feel self-conscious
it got to the point
eventually where it was just my voice no
matter what i said i would
hear it and i would hate it without a
tune on yeah
so you know i got a stoma but it was
like an auto-tuned stoma
yeah and so i was just permanently ah
yeah everywhere and anywhere but then i
would pull up to mcdonald's and i would
order and they would give me the travis
scott meal every time even if i didn't
want it
and and i couldn't shake it and then it
just it turned into like
you know uh uh
people just start treating me
differently what are you saying
i can't understand you take that thing
out of your voice and it's like i
thought you liked my voice like this
yeah yeah i really yeah i mean i i feel
like
kind of you know the the t-pain struggle
almost
you know it got to a point where people
would just non-stop what what if you
took it off
you sound so great without it but it's
like it's now my brand
[Laughter]
yeah wait so michael getting better at
singing i think like
i think you could get better with a
vocal coach
i think you you would get better you
like you're not you might not achieve
you know [ __ ] ariana grande or you
know some
insane power vocalist range but i think
it would definitely make you better
you know what i mean like yeah and that
way it would you would sound
good i guess like if if if you knew like
techniques and stuff and and and where
to how to push your voice and all that i
feel like you could it could play
but yeah there's so much of your voice
that you probably
haven't unlocked yeah like everybody the
average human only uses ten percent of
their voice
in their voice box they have another
ninety percent of their voice box that's
just
lying in weight that's something that's
what
gary v is going to be saying eventually
yeah you need to [ __ ] sing he'd say
yeah you you all need to sing everyone
should unlock that 90 percent
that inner ariana grande only difference
between you and ariana grande is that
she had that 90
unlocked already so if you just took a
class you could unlock the nine percent
i feel like that's the goal of being a
motivational speaker is like you just
have to
say so much [ __ ] in a small amount of
time that no one can question whatever
you just said and you just ram all the
information down their throat
and then all they leave with is like
damn i need to grind harder
yeah exactly exactly that's the overall
theme to everything
damn i really gotta get back on my grind
i'm not killing it enough i really need
to kill it more
that's the lesson you just gotta kill it
dude
you just gotta absolutely kill it more
yeah bro
you